you know one of the hardest things to
deal with in the streets is
when somebody killed anybody you love
at that point right there guess what the
gun is in your hand what you gonna do
is you're gonna take up for your man or
you're gonna be
even you will or you're gonna go take up
for your brother your best friend your
cousin your uncle whoever what you gonna
do
[Music]
the first time i got shot i got shot
right here
left out of my head
and went into my shoulder
well still right there
so it went in my head and came straight
out
yeah all them bullet holes
got two right there
but as i'm getting older i can start
feeling it now though my knee can't
shine my knee point blank
shot my elbow too
all together i got shot 22 times
we have seen a rise in homicides this
year and last year because there is a
gun culture in d.c that culture that
leads people to think that the only way
they can protect themselves to keep
themselves safe is to have a gun
i'll rather be caught with a gun than
without a gun
it becomes a way of life in our
particular community there
we've done a little research on
why kids pack
the answer is pretty simple
the other kids are packing and they're
stealing your lunch
you know the american express cliche
don't leave home without it
read 38 or else you shouldn't go outside
once you got that mindset like it's jail
or death every day whenever you wake up
in the morning that's your outcome you
know okay the police ain't gonna come
this morning okay cool you're gonna
strap up you're going outside
somebody's getting you away you're gonna
kill them or they're gonna kill you
they're kids who are cognitively morally
and ethically immature
and they're armed with semi-automatic
weapons
it becomes an easier way to deal with
what's occurring when they have a
dispute about tennis shoes dispute about
a basketball game dispute about uh how
you look them your dispute about this is
my territory they sell it so easily with
a gun because the availability is there
trying to rob this boy
the person that poses set up for me went
and told him
so they knew i was coming
they let me have it
he stood over top and shot me 17 times
and i don't know why that boy did not
bend down and put that gun to my head
and in me
a byproduct of the defund the police is
this resistance to cooperate
neighborhoods that have had a difficult
at best relationship with the police
that relationship sunk even further and
therefore willing to take matters into
their own hands to settle disputes
you can get what are called ping pong
shootings or ping pong murders where one
side shoots a guy and the other side
shoots a guy and you get this constant
classic cycle of revenge
how can you not want retaliation when
somebody just kill your little brother
i don't care who you are you're gonna
think about it
my little brother
god be told i lost him when he was 18.
people killed him man
had a very useful retaliate
i wouldn't want nobody to be in that
position because you know why
really man you throwing your life down
the river evil way you go
it's a no-win situation
that's the pressure your family your
friends your neighbors everybody gonna
put on you when somebody kill your
brother
many witnesses are afraid that if they
cooperate with the police they'll be
subject to retaliatory violence that's
not an unreasonable
fear
you deal with the police you'll snitch
cut and dry
it's a bad luck in the hood people won't
talk to you people don't want to do
business with you you're pretty much an
enemy
in the life of a street police officer
you haven't lived unless you look a kid
in the eye and they basically say you
i'm not going to talk to you
so we've had several cases in the last
few months where
kids are killed even and no one talks
if people believe the cops are going to
keep them safe and that there will be a
swift response to a violent offense they
are less likely to need to protect
themselves
white people want people to go to jail
black people want to stay on the streets
so they can kill them
you